Trump says he wants to punish General
Motors for its restructuring plan that
could cut up to 14,000 jobs and close
five auto plants the president tweeted a
threat to scrap GM's government
subsidies though it's unclear if he has
the power to do that on his own Dean
Reynolds is at a GM dealership in
Chicago Dean good morning good morning
the White House has told GM that the
president feels betrayed by a decision
many of those job cuts could fall in
areas of the Midwest where candidate
Trump campaigned on reviving
manufacturing holiday season layoffs
from GM brutal brutal frustration at the
White House over General Motors decision
to idle five North American plants
boiled over to anger seems like GM would
rather build its electric cars in China
rather than in the United States leading
to a threat from the president who
tweeted we are now looking at cutting
all GM subsidies including for electric
cars just minutes after that
presidential warning Wall Street
responded with GM stocks dipping down
for the day almost simultaneously as the
president's tweet they should have done
this a long time ago automotive industry
expert Jean Jennings says GM's
controversial decision was not
surprising well I'm at cusp of a new age
of Transportation and that
transportation will be electric it will
be autonomous as GM looks to the future
in Detroit we're still trying to figure
out what exactly this might mean for us
the Hamtramck community is reflecting on
the sacrifices it made to welcome GM in
the 1980s there was a viable
neighborhood of thousands of houses
businesses churches that were bulldozed
to create this complex GM said in a
statement many of the US workers
impacted by these actions will have the
opportunity to shift to other GM plants
they can be cold yes it's just the way
it is nature of the business while some
workers were numb to the cuts others
felt fear for their future hail honestly
is like what
and late I don't know what to do next
now it's not surprising that the United
Auto Workers Union is unhappy with GM's
decision UAW president Gary Jones urged
the automaker to quote invest in the
American citizens who invested in you
John Dean Reynolds thanks very much Dean